one of the other things that I really
liked was how you talked about the
innate desire for people to feel like
they need to have someone to make
themselves whole and I think that that
is part of the jigsaw analogy itself
right that you have particular quadrants
of the jigsaw that you put together yeah
could you explain those yeah well so
originally it was the idea was like
you've got the obviously when the jig so
you start on the outside you've got the
four corners you know and this is
obviously different for different people
but in the analogy I use it was like
Fran's family job and hobbies like and
those are transferable they're different
from you and somewhere you know your
family my family is very important to me
so my friends and I'm first of all of my
job don't have any hobbies
there's no that Corner's obviously small
for me but for other people you know
maybe they [ __ ] hear their family
maybe their family is [ __ ] and maybe
they've only like three close friends
but they've got lots of hobbies and that
their job is an office or a consuming
thing and it's you know probably the
jacks analogy is people just don't
change over the years they're always the
same picture what is you change those
points when you just go [ __ ] I want
to be obsessed with my job anymore or
you know and my fault I want my family
but to be beggar now and you have to
sort of a move right so it's constantly
changing in their shifting thing that
the one thing we all want and is we all
feel broken if we don't have someone
there the reason we feel broken is
because of how we raise children you
know the TV shows everything is about
love everything is about relationships
you know our parents divorce is very
very common it's a very very common
thing there's nothing wrong with it but
divorce that was talking about for some
phones kids is very sort of taboo
because can't help kids that sometimes
love is wrong
you can't tell an eight-year-old that
they're gonna get it wrong so many
[ __ ] highness have so many times
before they get it right because that's
not what you want the story of you know
love to be when you you're seven or
eight years old right yeah you know it's
always the Disney Princess gets the
Prince of the Prince gets the princess
or it's always about these relationship
is the whole focus of ever every single
TV shows and I've done is even now when
I'm pitching TV shows they go who's the
lovely
like well I doesn't have to be a [ __ ]
love interest like why does my sure that
has nothing to do with love what is my
calculator why is that important they
your kids or Hargrove like it's people
just need to know a lot of people feel
the desire to latch on to that
particular store even right it's a story
of hope and redemption for people who
don't have it and I guess a hope of
continuation for those who do mmm
yeah then again I've always said that
I've got nothing against relationships
and Jake's always never meant to be a
breakup show and it's not it's a love
letter to single people
I just took me so long to be secure with
being single they took me to know you
know especially family stuff when you
get mine from having kids you like
whenever I [ __ ] want yeah and if I
don't have them tough [ __ ] like get a
grandchild from your other kids I don't
care I've adorned all games and I was I
was it my business partners wedding a
few years ago him and his missus have
been together since they were 20 they
are the exact opposite the polar
opposite of my situation just about to
have their second child and they've got
two dogs and it is like the white picket
fence the British ones equivalent all
right whose wedding and we've been there
for the weekend it's been beautiful and
everything's amazing and the families
got on and the service is fantastic and
this not new there is I'm driving away I
can see his mom and a couple of her
family members just looking at me as I
drove past and I could just see in their
eyes they were thinking you're next and
I've found the window down as I won't be
soon there are there are different paths
in love life for different people
mm-hmm like in yeah ie so some of us are
don't get me wrong I'm an absolute
romantic like I want to I want to be a
dad more than anything in the world I
really really would do and I want to get
mind I want to have kids I want that I
just don't think I have to do it before
I'm 30 and I don't think I think I'm not
looking for it at all like I'm
thoroughly enjoying you know cuz I'm not
being in a relationship and not being it
that means I can be selfish as [ __ ] at
the moment and I can travel as much as I
travel for my job I can really focus on
and one day that will change one day
some god damn woman is going to come in
my life and just be perfect and I'm
going to you
ah I didn't realize that I was writing
all of these routines and it was yeah
I'm the [ __ ] hypocrisy oh my yeah see
what I get into a [ __ ] relationship
my fines are gonna be like you [ __ ]
what like I know I'm sorry she made me I
didn't mean to lay my heart look at her
with our [ __ ] perfect little laugh
that for some reason makes me feel warm
and say all that yeah I'm gonna be a
hypocrite I'm gonna be an absolute good
but no but I also won't be because I met
I'm not against relationships I'm
against fake relationships and the more
fake relationships that exist you are
it's it's it's a disease like you see
you'll say they go I'm so happy I'm so
happy in this relationship and you're
not but you'll lie to your friends that
are single and go I'm so hungry with
Jonathan or I'm so happy with Claire and
they'll go [ __ ] it now they get through
it they hate each other they get through
it yeah that's what we must must do and
you say you just go [ __ ] ID this
person I'll change who I am
you know everyone says it takes like why
why does that have to take what like if
you've got kids absolutely like if it's
but when you're just starting out like
well if I had to know if this might
sound insane and that's because I have
if I if if I'm in a relationship and we
have one argument in that first year bye
yeah like oh we have disagreements like
yeah I love he won't sign up on Peter I
don't wanna fluffy yeah yeah we could do
that but like if like let's see I get
fundamentally yeah like you I have a lot
of female friends who are my best
friends in the world is caught up in
friends with Jean for eight years we
left together she's one of my closest
friends if I was ever in a relationship
with someone who's like you need to see
Jean Lance I would be like you can
absolutely take a running fight to
yourself like it's you know that because
that's you that's that's either jealousy
which I've don't suffer from so it's
maybe you know I have any I don't have
any [ __ ] sympathy for it yeah because
it's those are your insecurities and I
had trust me I will do everything
through you found with someone I don't
want them to feel insecure you know I
think your job is to make that person
you know feel loved and valuable and
but you know even if you do that and
they're still [ __ ] jailers you're
like I can't ya know it's not my job to
fight the [ __ ] idea yeah yeah it's
not your job to fix me and it's not my
job to fix you
[Music]
you